everybody was cool as [ __ ] you know what
you brought tiffany haddish and i
listened to your podcast with tiffany
and i know how much you love her yeah
and i got a chance to finally meet her
when we filmed that episode and was
after yours
and man that chick is so so dynamic and
so charismatic
she has like a force feel that comes off
of her and you can speak to that because
uh it's funny because uh i don't know
how it was for you like in the jackass
days but you do stand up
you know now still and when you're
hanging out with someone that's used to
being in front of a live crowd
you know like her with her stand-up
crowd i mean she gets them people going
and me working a crowd you know twenty
thousand ninety thousand whatever
the stadium is you know there's that
there's that knowledge that you have to
it will burp christ there's another guy
tells us
another good story joel mchale but
tiffany haddish is flat out electric and
i love drawing your podcast
aw dude thank you so much i mean that
was the only podcast out of every single
one we've put up where the first thing i
said in the intro was
here's something you've never heard me
say this is the best podcast we have
recorded
because the artists yeah me too for sure
the arc of tiffany's story being in
foster homes in south central los
angeles and just like this
this trying just tragic upbringing and
the way that she wrote
like like rose meteoritically with just
this
this beautiful energy this it's just
incredible man you can't talk to her
without
feeling inspired man that's how i'm glad
well i mean
she was listening on you know time you
know 100 top most influential people in
hollywood
and when she says she's going to do
something believe her because she's
going to do it
and on a side note we just didn't make
the show
but after we came off we went out on a
speedboat and when we got off that boat
we started talking about her track
career
from back in the day and i challenged
her to a foot race holy [ __ ]
yeah she smoked my ass
that's great yeah yeah she's a real
sweetheart
oh dude she's the best yeah
dude